I'm very happy to have it as a guest Kai
whiting native British guy he was living
in Portugal currently and who I thought
I would interview not only because we
have a common interest in stoicism but
also because he is an expert among other
things in the field of sustainability
something that I think a lot of people
talk about but but not a lot of people
are very precise about so why don't you
tell people how you got interested in
that and also in stoicism and maybe what
the confluence of those things are I
would like to say that nobody V Michael
is very has this work very well defined
it's quite a loose term people tend to
outside of my field think sustainable
development as living off the animal
roots and plants and that's one
component we are free so I tend to focus
more me environmental aspects but I do
have the interlinked redesigned
economics because we live in their canal
system and if we will look after the
environment that involves labour rights
for example working conditions there
involves interactions between
corporations and local communities
sustainable development it's really
about occupying the safe space where we
in the present generations can provide
for our needs without compromising those
future being able to meet their own
needs and all the philosophers here
going to jump up and down now and say
future generations we have no obligation
toward them but what I say when I say
future generations in my field I mean
the people that plan now yeah right this
second they are the future generation
that I'm talking about
now in the London hospital person bomb
now in a New York Hospital
first of all now in hospital that is the
future generation for us so it's really
how we meet our needs without
compromising their ability or their
capacity to meet their own and it's
quite difficult because how can we
second-guess what they really really
need in terms of material aspects but I
think star isn't really helpful could we
can say well they certainly need justice
yeah
they certainly need the ability to
provide the need so that takes an hour
part of self control because the
opposite is agreed agreed not being very
good if you want to provide for future
generations and you're really not sure
what they need it takes courage because
they obviously it's cowardice in the
today's society you have a lot of
politicians I won't name names who are
saying no we want our things we want
them now it takes a lot of courage to
say actually we can have things we kind
of everything we want now and climate
change does exist
yeah very popular favorite and it
requires wisdom to know how to tackle
such statements in a post truth world
how to tackle them when tackle them and
what to do when we find someone who's
almost to help and as it were in
peddling mistruths half-truths and
peddling their own agenda sustainable
government is more in my definition
integral to stories by the very
definition without the virtues the
reason is sustainable development and
the opposite stand development is
devices
well it's integral in another way to
write because with we're talking about
moderate stoicism we're looking at
adaptations that go beyond the framework
but but use the framework of the ancient
thinkers who didn't anticipate for
example us being able to ruin the
environment wholesale or exhaust natural
resources so that they couldn't be
passed on
you know you think about the situation
we're locked into with fossil fuels yeah
present so they're not running out yet
but they will run out at some point in
time because nobody can make new ones
okay so you know that seems to me to be
one of those things with stoicism if
it's going to be adapted to the modern
context we have to they have to take
some cues from that absolutely I mean
even if you don't run out of them
he's [ __ ] something that we really
feel as sterics or any human being on
the earth
regardless that philosophy our plaintiff
did we really think that fracking to the
point that people are having nosebleeds
mass water contamination mass
environmental destruction even seismic
activities do we really think that is
justifiable provide cheap energy because
of our greed or our perceived needs
there are that expense it's good its
interest occurs I mean I suppose you
have something sort of like this with
with the units it states but we have
been all these different states in the
United States and each one has its own
local government on its own you could
call it political culture and they've
been you know some of them have embraced
fracking wholesale and you're seeing
things like that where they've sucked
out the water table or these these salt
areas and now they're having strange
seismic events and I mean you could say
it's nature if you want to answer more
classes in a chair you know sort of
coming back and taking its toll but it's
really just physical processes right I I
certainly believe that regardless if you
believe in God or you don't
it's out of God's sort of directions of
asking people really is this why I
created the earth for or it's literally
like there are consequences to our
actions and as human beings have to say
we are the we are obnoxious enough to
have to have an Earth Day
I mean don't recognize the fabulou on
earth every day we only recognize it
yeah well and I think most people don't
don't recognize it that either right
it's crazy isn't it what about this is
something that we talked a bit about
before
on our own and in that article that we
worked on what about the scope for
animals because an ancient stoicism they
made it very clear break between
rational things that just just be us and
then the gods or Die motifs or whatever
whatever happens to be above us and then
all the brute animal creatures and then
plants below you know we know a lot more
now because of animal behavior that
perhaps there's more rationality of some
sort some are the animals do we have to
revise the stoic take on of animals I
just want to just I identified two
people might not read our paper what we
try to do yeah we hope that were
Neandertals rational just to kind of
have a highbreed literally between what
we used to consider as the animal
kingdom in our mind says say so many
religious people and what we saw today
and the end of tools were the
interesting case of how human do you
have to be before you infested by this
human I won't tell you much here but I
think that we have to leave according to
the facts and you know if regardless if
you believe that God created the earth
and therefore humans are you know
everything else is subservient or you
believe that humans are the pinnacle of
evolution
I was says a stoic for according to the
facts that's not correct
we're not the pinnacle of human
evolution if we have a spiritual aspect
we can't prove that according to fact we
can say that animals are suffering and
we can say that God would not warrant
all like excessive suffering
I had this debate yesterday actually and
said you know is is there such thing as
objective morality and it stirs them
there is Jude omnia but that unit of
Minea does not apply to animals so if we
want to break out into really how we
should treat animals according to
well-being and some kind of quote
unquote
more activity it would require more than
finding out whether they ration or not
and I don't have a clear answer because
Rossum is very clear that objective
morality is to do with the four virtues
and by definition a chimpanzee has no
understanding what justice means because
they have not got the rationality to do
so so on the summon about don't think we
have to branch out I think we have to
create a completely different way of
wonder I wonder though you know you're
right that so stoic morality is based in
large part on the four branches but not
entirely so that's what the story is
different from the cynics in things like
that so the realm of the indifference
and what Cicero speaking for Cato so we
think this is pretty reliable because
the primary impulses or principles of
nature and you know the other stoic
facts about this in terms of what they
also some self-perception and so it
seems like there's there's something
going on there that deals with the realm
of a preferred and rejected indifference
and that's that's also the realm of
appropriate acts or duties and sounds
it's never it never amounts to the same
thing as exercising the virtues or
having them Isis I suppose one of the
other good things funny animals that
so we can't truly have a vise yeah
exactly
but we do have the new ins and I am
looking at like for example and I will
be talking about this tourist icon is if
we consider that Quentin nature is very
important then separating a mother from
her calf is not allowing that calf to
leave a point in nature and if they
think that's important then I don't
think on strike principles we can
justify too much eating of ice cream
which is something very hard to to
tackle but do we or do we not agree that
every living thing should be allowed
within whatever range we you know we
decided is reasonable should we then
justify our walk for a milkshake in the
morning and something that is helping on
literally reducing that relationship
between mother and calf as much as
possible yeah you know it's a challenge
and I think factory farming that's
arisen over the last you know 30 40
years as an industrial practice driving
out other other farming practices is
really problematic in a way that maybe
you know previous farming wasn't that
could have been problematic as well but
just the sheer scale and the cruelty and
brutality that's that's shown by people
to love the animals the reduction simply
to sort of meet machines or milk
machines it seems like it Corson's us
you know it's interesting too so we have
different because they have a different
take on the domestic animals than we do
on the wild animals maybe with the wild
animals we should you know protect their
habitats and stop hunting them or you
know reduce the numbers that we're
hunting or manager the hunts very well
the way it was where I grew up and live
you have to hunt deer because otherwise
they'll hold everything but it can be
managed very well it can be done with us
as little cruelty as possible so there's
that but then you know the domestic
animals were kind of in a pickle because
we've already gotten millions of them
that have been bred solely to you know
produce go for it to make as much pork
as possible to be to be meat developed
it up in a certain way what do we what
do we do with them I mean they're not
simply domesticated towards that but we
have kind of messed around with their
nature have absolutely I mean a cow you
know survive we don't kill it to give
birth and then I think that's only true
are these funny because people say oh
that's terrible you're saying you should
kill those cows that and like so if I
banned slavery does that mean I should
kill all the slaves that's not how we
found slavery it's a process of saying
I'm not saying we shouldn't say had milk
and I'm not saying that we should
necessarily cure not kill a cow what I'm
suggesting is that mainly a counter to
floor so you can have veal it's very
very difficult thing and actually on the
state kind of restaurant menu the
evening there's be honest I'm sure that
people can smell and ask is it stoic me
too
and I think the answer is what
principles you want later do you want to
live according to nature and do you want
to allow that count to do the same thing
or do you think that the most of meat in
your mouth is worth more and then I
might question your aspect of several
trials but until the bargainable is I I
don't think hunting if I hunt or I don't
have makes me less remorse to it because
you have left and you will live
according to its nature if it's okay to
overhunting yes because it's like a self
control and so when somebody has or
recently these things I think their kid
you could like not over hunt could be
hunting for the wrong reasons I grew up
in the countryside so most people that I
knew consider shot there are some people
who are clearly Satanists and just the
law of turning animals and then there
were some [ __ ] essentially you know
stewards through hunting and then
everything in between you know so you
know it's very difficult to call the one
out from the process because so much of
it is done out in the countryside yes
but I think it's a question of I'm not
trying to hear every single hunter
around every some kind of important book
you know intently book and hit people
around the page what I'm saying is if
you're stoic and you want to leave a
pointer straight principles then you
have to still really question your
motives for hunting and if the way that
you honey allows the animal
that can really convey your concern for
live their living according to nature
according to the earnings yeah yeah I
mean it would certainly rule out big
game on Jiang or traveling to other
states to get trophies or like that
trophy hunting that's really about greed
or lack of self control sometimes our
it's nice to throw fees when maybe the
kind of pride right right honors yeah I
say to them making clay pigeon suit if
you rewrite as a trophy then you can
clay pigeon shooting I
I think hunting is an important aspect
for many people's lives and I wouldn't
say it like somebody asked me very
recently is it going to own a gun I'm
like so if you only gun does that mean
you're more stock than I am that's me
not owning a gun I mean I'm more stout
than you know owning a gun does not make
you more or less - it's how you use the
gun yeah that's that's the realm of
praises or dealing right there for use I
think a gun means just one thing you
owned a gun that it doesn't mean
anything else it doesn't describe any
morality whatsoever
whereas say denying climate change to me
it means that you are unwilling to look
at the facts and therefore I would say
that you are diverging from the stoic
calling to leave a clue into facts and
according to nature and the concerns
that people have over the Pacific
Islanders who actually drown the fires I
think of the sea level rising and I just
listen to New Zealand's UN talk with
Jacinda the current prime minister and
she talked about you can talk about the
science all you like but there are
people on these islands who can tell you
as children that the sea was this bar
and now my village is going under yeah
so if you're saying climate change
doesn't exist it's fake booze well don't
read the science go and travel to
Pacific Islands
you know it's interesting we can observe
that I don't know what it's like you
know hear it and Britain in terms of
that but Wisconsin where I live we used
to have snow on the ground where you
could cross-country ski really from
November all the way to end of March and
now it doesn't stick you know so you
know that there's there's something
different and we have species that are
invading both plant and animal you know
one way you can tell is that the
blackberries as opposed to the black
raspberries are are doing better you
know that's that's one of the plants
that's moving north and choking out the
native wildlife and you know the other
thing is to our military firmly believes
that there's there's climate change and
so does the rand Institute and all these
think tanks except the political ones
because they're planning for the
destabilizing effects that's going to
have throughout the third world and
they're very worried about it but you
know and this is something I'd like to
ask you about because you've got your
your finger much more on the pulse than
I do
I've got the impression that in America
you know we have one political party
that's somehow firmed up firmly
committed to thinking that climate
change is just a hoax and that's the
Republicans and it didn't it wasn't
always that way they there used to be
much more rational and you know they'd
sort of spare they go back and forth
sometimes the Democrats are more
rational about things sometimes the
Republicans but it wasn't this sort of
wholesale nope doesn't exist that that's
a silly lie and I have the impression
that conservative parties that are the
equivalent of the Republicans
and many other first world countries
just didn't have that antique climate
change
notion that this you know they were
perfectly willing to say there is
climate change it was just a question of
well are we going to try to change it
through through tax structure or carbon
offsets or you know how is it going to
happen but you know it strikes me that
maybe I'm wrong about that and given
some of the right regimes that have been
that have come up recently that seem to
take their cues more from looking at say
that the Trump administration maybe I'm
wrong about that maybe they're there are
more deniers here in Europe I think the
irony is the Conservative Party of the
u.s. doesn't normally like change they
should be actually throw yes I haven't
change measures because climate change
by definition to changing conservatives
by definition don't like change is kind
of in the tail but I would say in the on
the right there has been since I would
say the Clinton administration the need
for the individual to outshine and you
can't solve climate changes in
individual yeah it's it's not about
climate change it's about the fact that
the Trump administration likes to solve
problems in social that show the world
what they can do so they can go to North
Korea and making sure the world that
they can shake hang where no one has
shook hands before yeah and they can do
it because Barack Obama got a Peace
Prize and they can get one too but they
can't solve the climate change issue on
their own and therefore it doesn't exist
because that is what the Trump
administration is about well but the
Republicans were on that take before
I mean there was a lot of pressure to
the Bush administration especially from
the Tea Party not signed on to because
you guys you like to think for some
reasoning pole opposites
if the Conservative Party thinks this
way then the Democratic Party has to
think almost the opposite and I kind of
think that it's just definitively
circles I I don't actually think that
climate change has it just it's the
victor sounds really cynical on my part
but it just feels like the victim of
well if we say it's a collective issue
if we say that we should do some
accounting that sounds like a Democrat
policy and in ways the difference that's
that's where we currently are in our
political system unfortunately we we
have a we now have a political system
that over the last two decades has
become extremely dysfunctional which is
terrible for a nation that's supposed to
be a world leader because it means
people are looking at us and and we have
these two warring sides both led by a
political elites who have very little
connection with with ordinary people
that might have been groomed and tied
into a lot of different industries and
and there's really no way to change it
unfortunately other than at the local
level because in order to get it there
try to change it you have to become one
of them I mean and you know I I don't
see things getting better States
unfortunately and and that mean that
means a lot of problems for everybody
else in the world so you know how much
can focus on sustainability let's say
the EU worked out some of its kinks and
really had the political will to to do
things in a big way how much could they
change without the u.s. being on board
or China or or India really major
countries used to work in China they've
made huge leaps and bounds they know
that they have to do it they know in
Beijing they have a massive negative
actual problem I was living in Hangzhou
and it was the first city that banned
motorbikes and didn't run on electricity
so I think a lot of people are ignorant
of what China is doing and the u.s.
likes to feel that they're very very
important and of course because of the
sheer numbers and other political status
of the year as they are important and I
do think the US can change because it
has a potential to do that does have the
potential more than say other smaller
countries to change something really
quickly because when you get behind in
the u.s. once you get behind an idea it
really does change quicker than say some
of their only European
and people stuck in their legs so I'm
looking at the Democratic Party which
was really disappointing to me so man
heliopause years ago I couldn't go into
my reasons why but now I'm seeing that
you know second-generation immigrants
taking out pieces oh wait a minute I'm
American too and I couldn't imagine that
two years ago so there's been a whole -
a backlash towards the current
administration so I'm not so pessimistic
two wars at least the Democratic Party
the Republicans
well I think at the moment they're just
trying to survive and keep their head
above water and it's difficult to say
when when the next elections coming on
how many of them jump super cheap I'll
plug the hole so I'm not quite a few
than they have already in the
legislature many of them decided not to
run for office for an additional term
because they saw themselves as disabled
by some of the causes but you know our
votes in our legislature almost all
along party lines and there's so much
emphasis on controlling state
legislators because on those draw the
lines that decide where the districts
are that some people say Congress so
there's there's so much that would need
to change one of the analogies that I
like to say so we've got a constitution
that's one of the oldest you know
written constitutions and that's
sometimes a bragging right but it's not
actually a good thing in many respects
because you know look at the indian
constitution right it's been amended now
i think at least a hundred times since
1900
and it's fairly easy to amend it when
what else need it we we don't have the
the capacity to do that with a gridlock
political system and so we have
something that's like the equivalent of
having a very old car you know that just
you can keep cobbling it together and
adding new parts but it it just can't
pass standards it's the way that younger
you know better designed things can but
it's the one we're stuck with and we
have to keep driving it and we have to
keep on adding new parts to it and you
know pouring more fuel and the attitudes
and so just to keep the thing running
when you guys here don't don't have a
constitution it has you know you've had
you have one for longer but it's always
been an unwritten one so people made
about what exactly it is I think it's
very stranger than I hear about that
strange Christian idea it's probably the
founding fathers think of this like did
they know a car look like did they know
that climate change was nation oh wait
they you know why that I don't feel to
cut is funny funny question though we
have the founding fathers finger that
unlike wherever they fall would be
completely irrelevant
and most the issues that are still
having are in every store are so as such
an American like Rockland just it seems
a much new difference when you're not
leaders
the founding fathers would be really
really unhappy with this and like how do
you know if they have you asked them no
cuz they're dead within there's a long
time that would be a three thing that's
hilarious we think like right and I do
understand that haystack or analysis is
important but I finally agree with you
know make sure like they asked me what
were what were the Barons you know I've
thought about that or what about grammar
what would be a [ __ ] okay we've been in
the conquer Ford about those things yeah
but we get stuck but we get stuck about
that interesting when I get Seneca said
this oh yeah
like really and I find it comes from the
more sort of religious side because
people like to have those and you know
in terms of just the word atheist means
I do not believe in God there is no God
it just tells you what you don't believe
it doesn't tell you what you do so I
think that when you're going to stir
them and if you come from religious
background even if it over lives anymore
you're looking for some kind of comfort
you're looking for whoever said what and
so I would say well you know us are the
concern about laugh you know they're our
guides now our masters and that just
throws a lot of people oh so I can
understand when the Americans want the
Constitution and they feel like
comfortable in it but I do think that
some stage you have to realize that
there are some Hebrew T's to do
maintaining a 200 and 300 year story and
we are present-day situation but I am
very optimistic about what the Americans
do because that's good I think that
somebody else has to be Oh Jack's
bootlegger fan we had years and years
and years of Sappho guys turn around
Sir Richard you've compared to football
no more football yeah sake it's much
more difficult because of the way the
mantich and I would always win and then
Chelsea would always win and you would
never get like the really bad team
winning so I think America has people
eat do it
it's whether they have the political
will to do it well in the case of
American football and also baseball the
way they did that was by the putting the
salary caps right because otherwise you
know the teams like the New York Yankees
in baseball could just buy everybody and
win that way and there were teams like
that football is good so I don't I don't
know that they don't have do they have
something like that in soccer
we tried to do that maintainers
communist okay
we fully say the only thing communist
about Americans in sports because their
worst team gets the first pick that's
true yeah I'm not quoting to their needs
thank you I think it's fantastic I feel
really excited that you never get a peg
a I'm just going to that's never gonna
get better if you went to our local team
and it wasn't awesome oh well you always
look into gets the better team yeah okay
you have got the Patriots and you've got
green baize you know but it's not what
we're not doing that well Wow how much
is gonna have to bear as are actually
leading our division right now other
that's paint ways to fix well not for me
because I'm actually a Packers and Bears
okay but that's very rare a lot of
people think I'm a traitor because of
that oh yeah I'm sure I've Green Bay
fans would say but I guess like in one
year you can change the season around I
think if there's enough political will
and there
get tired feel strongly about it I think
there is enough I mean there was
something two days ago retreat excites
me in Malaysia never weather the
Conservative Party leaning papers here
were worried about the Labour Party and
generally all Ben was saying because
they're like wait a minute we may have
really bad ideas at the moment in the UK
but he is winning and he's talking about
climate change he's talking about
recognising the Earth Sciences estate
which is know many political suicide
yeah and even the Conservative Party is
saying wait a minute we're gonna have to
listen to some of this because people
are for that so I do think the Republic
of Hawaii will have to tell you a
slightly different line on in two years
time because if people are well it'll
certainly show in this midterm election
and you know there's predictions all
over the map about just how big of a
swing it could be but I think if they
get it big enough kick in the pants and
some of them will will start worrying I
don't think Trump will start worrying I
don't think many of the people around
him right though they'll go down with
that ship but I think I think some of
the other ones well you know and you're
right there maybe there is more reason
for hope you think about like say
smoking yeah when I was a kid the idea
that we would somehow ban smoking in
most buildings was just ludicrous my
mother and father smoked at the dinner
table when we were children and
and nobody thought anything of it we
smoked when I was in college in the
classroom right after class at the end
we would light up and and it must been a
hell for the non-smokers but they you
know they that passed these these acts
bit by bit by bit first it was public
buildings that it was bars and at each
point it was oh this is you know the
world
gbt right so yeah even in even when I
was kid you know everything that two men
would ever get mind about like some
crime scandal the other thing that there
would be a desire for our frozen
character of Disney film to be not
straight the only thing that would be
concern of people within in the last 10
years you've gone from oh my gosh it's
terrible it's my sinful scene at all to
even Latin America like saying actually
people can get married I mean Columbia
there's a case the freemen game knowing
like they they're happy to think about
how the law fits into that but that's
Columbia we're talking about
knockos you give you see now under you
know this is changing I think without
that issue you know through the broad
spectrum of gay rights for LG LG bt q
rights in general there were so many
people who were so emotionally invested
and and not just emotionally but
cognitively invested as well and there
being these things that would you know
couldn't be that way or if it did and
everything would break down and it took
so much energy to keep fighting and
fighting and fighting while at the same
time having to deal with the fact that
if you're you know if you're in a large
family you you definitely have somebody
who's who's gay or lesbian or bi or
transgendered or something like that in
their family you know I know from a
family of about 200 when we have a big
family reunion you know it's normal
proportions right so having to shut
people out like that of your life and
they took such a toll after awhile that
people had to come to terms with it and
start starting softening
you know so I mean how does it if we
bring that back to sustainability how do
we get people to start thinking in terms
of the generations to come and I'm a
philosopher by the way there's no
problem thinking about non-existent
generations that we have a debt to them
as well I understand that you know some
analytic philosophers are you know more
cuckooing that idea
maybe states to be happy even have that
debate even move in a narrow circle we
can't have a litigation before somebody
doesn't exist and it's like I'm not
talking about person doesn't exist I was
talking about president for 30 years ago
so I mean there is that challenge and I
think that it will only change when
people say in their life in the Quinn
example I always often give is that my
mum said to me when I was a kid I'm not
recycling it's not important I said fine
I'll recycle when I took this huge bag
well as you can see I'm quite sure I
realize a kid oh that's brilliant school
and I remember dragging this bag of on
the street and my mum felt really really
bad she's like it's too heavy for you
because your little she's brought over
me I'm talking like won the toy isn't my
family really a school family and I said
I don't care if it cost
and I remember dragging this bagger is
really really heavy and she recycles
more than I do you see because she saw
that yeah so I think education of kids
is the only thing that's going to you
know change ideas like in Kinta Mummy
smoking is bad you know smoking is bad
whereas 30 years ago I would never
kids would say that so we just I think
we need to reorganize that might be
education for children let's go why are
they talking square buildings with like
very small windows they'll be out in the
parks they should be out doing things so
that they can say mum why did we cut
that tree down oh because you know the
birds were in a cooing on my car mum
just moved the car you didn't have to
kill a tree so I think things won't
change if we make sure that I've changed
I know the things are rough in the same
way over here as they are over by us
where many of those programs that would
have gotten kids out about had been
viewed as not really cost-effective we
have to cut back
yeah I don't think people use the word
austerity so much anymore how they did
here near foreign cars well yeah that's
not the killer what idea yeah but you
know we for us it's all about justifying
things you know my my kids I come down
they they go to school yeah which is a
hard red state and every single school
is run by a school corporation there and
the state has mandated you know like
things like get them to this amount of
math or this amount of science and they
took the gym class which for me actually
is one of my favorite classes when I was
accepted about AJ everybody si what we
had to do it every year they only have
to do one year event but they have to do
it every single day so freshman year in
high school they have gym every single
day and then they have no gym classes
after that and the state is fine with
that
and then they wonder why they have you
know and be City epidemic and
you know kids who are unhealthy the
military is finding that they're having
trouble recruiting 18 year olds who
actually are healthy enough to go
through basic training and it's much
worse than the the red states than it is
in other places you know especially in
the south which used to be sort of the
backbone of military recruiting but now
because of the cultural dynamics and the
educational system they can't do that
and it's that way as well with music and
art there they're viewed as you know
extra necessary yeah even languages you
know my my daughter had the option to
take Spanish that was it you know when I
was a kid we could take Spanish French
or German and then in some schools
laughs that's that's gone and I know
that's going on over here as well that
it is yes people are saying of the
school field so that they can try out so
so how how do we educate the kids when
in ways that are going to lead to
greater emphasis on sustainability when
there's all these obstacles placed in
the way by the people who control
purse-strings and set the educational
priorities that's a very challenging
question I just a minute of paper review
response I wouldn't give too much
information away because I will come
back to talk to you about that we just
spoke about it I think I think
philosophers actually have a role
because people have to understand why
and the intrinsic value of nature when
you don't give nature some crime
intrinsic value the new CSIS is
important
if you don't add the circle concern that
it's the earth then every obligation is
towards your fellow human being and not
the environment in which you live yes so
there's there's that and philosophers do
actually set you know parts of the
curriculum and do kind of tell us which
orientation to go see if your philosophy
I do think that looking into nature and
how we should relate to it in a new
obligation that's one thing because I
imagine a lot of you listening to this
price quiet these classes that's how you
could to think about these things and
you know school isn't gonna provide
everything it never used to I'm sure
when you were kid you were on the street
running around and school didn't not
provide everything anybody who thinks
school but should provide everybody has
already lost about you know take your
kids out buy them say to them if you
want a camera you can have it but you're
gonna have to go and take pictures of
birds with me I'm not going to buy your
camera you know your birthday unless you
do unless you have a reason yeah
so it's about spending time a lot of
people say I can't spend telling my kids
I'm really busy but we'll take them with
you like I mean if you can take a baby
to the UN these days yeah I've have a
bad saying the first baby and I was the
first person to do that then you can on
some level take your children lot of
places and take them as young adults and
say look this is important to me my
father told me this my grandfather told
me that because I do think if we don't
do that the generation won't be able to
do that because they're grown father
would never have took them campaign they
would never have done took them fishing
or took them to their first hunt on
explaining traits it's important that we
respect nature so unfortunately the
school is not going to do it but who
said it's the school's responsibility in
fact in Stearns there may be quite the
opposite it would be ours principally so
I think philosophers need to gather the
classroom and into him into living
according to nature that's something
that we argue about taking the grain
back to the stove take back to the
marketplace to going back where
everybody is so even like the park
opportunities
it's not about being in a class and
telling people that they should be more
involved in nature that's that's
ridiculous
it's literally going I want to show you
how they use pen life I mean you must
add work do your kids know how to use
bondage ervice did you ever make sure
that they dipped and if you didn't then
maybe you should show them because
there's a lot of skills it's not just
being an agent skills of survival skills
of being able to be alone for five
minutes and not having to have a TV or
yeah it's about discipline when I was a
kid I think I was possibly one of the
last generations to be in nature and go
out right but I think in the land of the
internet where you can get their
Facebook groups and you can go on hikes
or you can turn being out nature into
how you get your Instagram photos
exactly enough done that we're students
they want to know how do we think about
urban and design environment I said well
I'll meet you next Tuesday outside the
street why was I gonna teach this if
we're not going to class well I'm not
going to teach you about the urban
environment in the classroom no we're
gonna see what what we think should be
dying this street because I always just
firstly can't get a job because they say
what practice if you had said well
actually had a piece of coursework where
or you know in my interest I want to be
a photographer totally do you have all
just self yeah I'd say it's about
looking for opportunities to build
community and these are outside and to
use the entire surrounding you have for
education which is what how you live
endowed Lisa yeah in an informal way I
mean now I live in downtown Milwaukee
we're fortunate that we have a lot of
green space in that city by comparison
to some others but I grew up in the
countryside and my kids were raised in a
different country side so so they got
plenty of that but it but it was kind of
rare many of the kids that were in the
countryside now I think are in fact
glued to TVs and video games tablets or
phones
so the if it's a different kind of rural
once the internet pervades and then the
urban see kids they don't want to go on
a day to the neighbors nature they want
to feedback this because that's the
current because they're playing I don't
know they're playing spider-man
spider-man Marvel's and once you do that
they where do they want to go on holiday
they want to go to Universal Studios but
who said that you should let your kids
decide absolutely everything you can
tell them we are only going to go to
Universal Studios when you can show me
that you have the skills of spider-man I
mean you could actually make a
seven-year-old wanna go or now you have
wanna go into those places so yeah I
said where there forty now it's very
difficult then find a different reason
they say okay we're gonna go come in and
then we're going to go to the Green Bay
game but we're not gonna go to the Green
Bay game until you could show me you
depend on that happen there are things
that can be done and it doesn't mean
that it's easy and even if you do live
say you even know you said New York City
you say it is virtually impossible well
you can still do urban garden you can
still fight out in Hong Kong helping
someone do urban gardening there's a
concrete jungle and so there's still
opportunities to look at you know go to
the Central Park there are enough of
June easy if you want to grab you know I
mean that's an interesting one with I
know that so we belong to a CSA in
Milwaukee that took some you know vacant
lots and turned it into an urban garden
it's very good for the local community a
lot of the kids get involved and then
then you know you buy into the CSA to
get
various groceries you know verbs
vegetables sometimes an eggs that sort
of thing and and there must be something
like that in New York City as well and I
know that when we were living in New
York there was a massive lot of kids who
wanted to be able to farm but couldn't
you know afford to buy him to farming
property and so they were apprentice in
out to the farmers here and there to
learn the trade and then sometimes they
did you know take out a bank loan and
something sells out but it seems like
you know there was a lot and you're
gonna know much more about this and I
recently passed in France at buildings
over a certain size the roofs either
need to be solar or they need to be
greases amenity and so it seems like
that's right they opens a vast
possibilities from rooftop gardens it's
just not being done very very much right
it's not because it's not efficient in
terms when an engineering standpoint I
guess but I think it's about consuming
opportunities and not allowing because
it is very efficient from the human step
it's extremely so it protects the roof
you suddenly get birds and butterflies
it's you know I think that Beijing could
be solved if they could just make every
single bird building some kind of living
building but instead they're sticking
plastic grass to decide the buildings to
open and I saw that Columbia drove me up
the wall like come on you could actually
do something here you know we had to
like an urban roof from the first day it
was like to show me how wonderful we
were and hang my head it's a great
marketing tool and it actually had real
war
very pleased you know it's posted a
plastic gardening our plastic flowers
yeah they were even they say no really
I'm really poor I can't do it there's no
space okay then buy your kid a cat and
tell your kid you have to look after
that until your kid you can you know
walk with them we made our cat walk you
know we taught how to get this cat they
won't lead yeah and you say how do you
how do you make a cat walk alongside you
a lot of work a lot of yeah yeah I I
tried doing that with cats but I kept
from kittens and I never I wasn't
consistent every day and that's the same
thing sustainability is everything so do
they ask you about earlier when we were
talking about animals and I thought
about cats because you know they kill so
many other animals and I love cats
actually I can't person but I know just
how are cats when I lived in the
countryside were inside outside cats and
they would they would hunt in packs and
bring kills all the time
and then you know you find other animals
scattered around the yard here and there
so you know when it comes to some of
these domesticated animals it's sort of
like the the problem with what do we do
with all the cows are all that the swine
that we have we have a you know
significant feral cat population
in the united states and feral dogs to
have more more feral cats and we have so
many other domesticated cats well
they're not truly domesticated the way
dogs are you know is it is it in
accordance with nature they have pets
like that you know are we setting up
little killers devastate you know
various not important up there any any
biome they come in contact with really
because they're they're one of the most
effective killers the only more
effective killer as far as i can think
of is us you know in terms of the number
of animals that they prey upon you know
it's over ten thousand you know cats are
a challenge and i have to say okay i
know you can't out cat just like tech
facts never really upset me yeah but
they don't say okay then you can be
better telling if you're better and then
the me that they hung in a bit oh I say
we say yeah like start with you like and
I think at some I think for kids are
important because you have at each kid
that finding woman I wouldn't say yeah
remove your cat's paw right says if
you're concerned about your car eating
out anymore then why don't you stop
eating animals yourself yeah that's
something that you can do you can't
control your cat is the thing to try to
do well they wouldn't work at it any we
working so I mean cats that much very
difficult yeah I mean so I see start
with yourself and if that is what are
you concerned and you know
oh if I have meat in my house because
I'm feeding a cat is that is that right
but then that cow was me you need of a
home so I didn't go out and buy accounts
give him the cows every way it's going
to really struggle because very very mr.
player they followed me around
everywhere so I think that people will
always find that extreme PC but you have
a cat I'm like you've been away but now
I think I hit by car but yes even if I
had a cat I still cut back on my own
things but I still say okay is it enough
to do what I'm doing should I not go
further my change now is because I like
eating cheese and going on but I'm
stopping you know stopping paddled
living according to nature do you think
that when it comes to that sort of thing
there's there's a lot of people you know
that proverb letting the best with the
enemy they good yeah well they use has
the excuse me you're not perfect well no
I'm not trying to be Jesus Christ I'm
not trying to be a god I'm just trying
to progress towards virtue and I think
they use the excuses I'm not gonna cut
me because you haven't caught up cheese
and they usually get that argument okay
I'm not asking you to come at me I'm
saying that if you want to leave
according to stoic principles
do you really know where that came and
so they use it as the easiest way to
defend their the inconsistencies is just
take mine I'm like I'm very aware of
mine where are you aware so I've never
had someone who really is hot you know
really worried about cats
I'm here for the point of view that
maybe they should not have one they're
usually argue or 99% of time argue
because I have one and they still hate
their beef
can you see how that's ridiculous I
think sustainability is like eudaimonia
it's a pro it's a process and we may
never ever get there because we will
never never ever know exactly what
future to Hirose it's late but if we can
move or inch closer to what the thing is
just what we consider to be justice yeah
what we consider be self-controlled then
we are more likely together and I know
that instances are still drown but you
drowned you know putting up a fight so
he like it is difficult but that's the
beauty of sustainable development
allowance it's not like oh yeah I
achieved this did you do your best
did you leave the world in the bad place
when you were born or did you leave it
for cigarettes smoked beer cans and the
did you just you know kill noise of
coils everywhere yeah did you do that or
did you contribute to something great
did you leave the kids with the ability
to survive camping did they value
something beyond their PlayStation 4
game that's that's what life's about
regardless if you believe in God or not
right is to make the most of what you
have here and to progress towards and
more
Fannin's equilibrium yeah you know one
of the think one of the things that we
see with the Stoics over and over again
is so we're supposed to live in
accordance with nature had a lot of
different framings for that but they
also talked about over and over again
and the insulation yeah be in harmony
with other human beings
Marcus is particularly you know keen on
pushing that but he's talking to himself
I'd support more more than us and so he
must have struggled with that quite a
bit that using that as a criterion
there's the question of whether I'm
consistent within myself in terms of my
general concepts and how I'm applying
them and my desires and you know actions
and choices all of that and anyway we're
all a mess when it comes to that but
then yeah Marcus keeps stressing over
and over again even those those people
who have got it wrong somehow you have
to align yourself to be able to get a
log on okay yeah it's not trying to for
example I have a wooden Redmond wing and
I wear them because I know what God is
like and I'm gonna work to Columbia I
know which shouldn't go down that mine
collapses in on them knowing that
knowing that the majority of go does not
come from the gold mine
a little small informal mind not
necessarily illegal but informal minds
and a lot of humor sent in a very small
basket hanging on a very interesting
piece of rope and they literally get
crushed I couldn't you know by
definition that has a stoic thing you
know I should have gone knowing where so
it's a question of you know reducing my
ignorance and once I know saying okay I
really have to be consistent with this
and the piece of wood was actually from
a door on a boat I didn't even kill
shrieks I thought is it necessary to
kill a tree people said to me oh but you
know your wedding wing it won't last
forever I'm like year but my commitment
will I just replace you God won't let us
for everything exactly and so they say
yeah but what does that mean exactly it
means it under now tell me if they
really go on my case no with me today
glad dripping from my finger like you do
so but it's about you know progressing
becoming steadily wiser and then once it
you've really internalized that wisdom
because one thing is knowing like yeah
oh yeah I know that okay so no I mean do
we know is then to make steps the right
steps towards where you want to bang
doesn't mean that and I think it's
philosophers that we have a real big
problem because we could have some
really bad ideas think they're really
good ideas and then tell the audience
they're amazing and they would believe
us was the ignorant fool he could
actually be right he would even know he
was right I wouldn't listen to it so if
you're a philosopher that you have a
really real obligation to change not
only other people's bad ideas but the
good ideas that you hold yourself that
you'll never hold something you think is
a bad idea because you're better at
speaking and because you're better
explaining yeah you better make sure
that what you explain is accurate
because otherwise people will believe
you not the a camera for what happens to
be right so here's a good thing that's
sort of depend on maybe the criterion
for whether maybe one criterion hurt
whether you're doing that properly is
that you live in accordance with
whatever it is you're preaching about
which I think you know I know plenty of
ethicists who are terrible people you
know being able to teach academic
philosophy this that doesn't actually
make you better in many respects it can
make you worse because there's this
institution I thought for practice so
should that be the criterion that I mean
would that mean that every philosopher
that has to be a philosophy of life I
think that I mean I I don't drive
because I don't want to stand up and say
you know I don't know maybe half but I
never learned to drive because I know
that I would be tempted to get in a car
and I would be able to say no I'm not
cycling today Lisbon's is really healing
I became vegetarian because I didn't
want to stand on my so-called pulpit and
say that the worst contributor to
climate change is agriculture
particularly intensive farming and
cattle farming yeah and then you saw me
eating a steak I they never be
completely ridiculous but my colleagues
in the faculty have criticized me over
and over again about why I'm so extreme
and I'm like extreme I'm just no
hypocrite
okay yeah so I think first if you don't
live the life and really you know I
don't really think you can call yourself
a philosopher by the standards that the
anxious doctor would have said you're
living it marketing you just say things
because he wanted to say you know I
really have yeah and if you don't live
it then it's just it's just academic
ivory tower of stuff and in which case
I'm very glad we have pay walls so you
can stay away from people I do think
that
however much philosophy you have you
have the obligation to live it because
then you starts to see the flaws because
you go actually what I'm saying makes no
sense so when you're complete dialects
of every level it's actually living like
a nihilist when every single level once
there ever doesn't really make much
sense
and so when I have philosophical
discussions it becomes quickly operative
obvious who lives what yeah so yeah that
would be my number one all for myself is
to live what I'm saying and then it
makes no sense
it's how about living it wrong
absolutely is actually an unjustified
badly so yes we should always we believe
and criticize our own beliefs and
criticize others think that way become
bad philosophers and we become better at
sustainable development only yeah that's
a great thought to end on thanks very
much for getting together with me we're
gonna head off soon to have some dinner
stoic on us tomorrow so I'm really
looking forward to all that I'm not
gonna get to hear your talk thank you or
no I will because you're in the plenary
yes right I can't hear anybody else's in
the panel for the breakdown seconds yeah
which is always a problem yeah so we'll
get there so that's good thank you find
me and this is GC
I think it will be yes
you